si preannuncia un gioco veramente non è
vero ho mentito a me stesso e me ne sono
accorto troppo tardi
bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vj quella è la mia
amica questo gioco si chiama if you have
a drink freehand se hai un amico ubriaco
la tipa era là in fondo si preannunciava
un bel gioco finché non è partita per
nebula 5 new game ha poi anche puoi
selezionare il personaggio trova bene
mio personaggio è team che pesa 78 kg
con daisy che ne pesa 48 perché dovrebbe
essere importante il peso delle persone
in questo gioco premi vs di premi il
tasto sinistro per alta stesso però
dalla camera previta sul sinistro per
prendere io posso muovere ma dai
quindi io posso possono afferrare le
cose bellissime
ha quindi possa afferrare gli oggetti va
bene eccola qua ho messo la pianta sul
tavolo più o meno con due mani prendi il
coso e posiziona lo è nella giusta
posizione va bene dami da mm a loro
posizionare gli va bene capito però io
sono più briaco dei miei amici scusami
se non mi sembra di essere molto sobrio
ok ho fatto ciao la tua mica bisogno di
riposare sofà e mi sa chi ci ha bisogno
di riposarsi chi so fa è un'ottima
soluzione va bene la mettiamo sul sofà
via inizi a no vieni che devi riposo 6
ubriaca vili fai vedere che youtube è
anche un posto dove c'è cultura vieni
qua insegnava ai propri amici come
riprendersi scusami se ti sto toccando
nè per causa di forza maggiore
devo metterti sul divano e farti
riposare perché sei ubriaca bene a posto
ok credo che quella mostra miglior
posizione per riposarsi però va bene
prendi un cuscino il cuscino anche
cuscino prendi cuscino tieni adesso sì
che ti riposi ti voglio sapere il posto
dove hanno bevuto perché vi prego in
cosa vedo quindi l'obiettivo di questo
gioco e far sì che la propria amica non
si spacchi di brutto
ascolta zia e sembra una cosa veramente
brutta questa che sto facendo però io
devo fare in modo che tu non ti faccia
del male capito non ti fare del male
senti c'è un bagno qualcosa dove posso
farlo
non lo so cosa ha bevuto ragazzi io
vorrei provare farla star tranquilli no
mi dovevo soffiare il naso perdonami
dicevo stai qui
secondo me non si fa del male adesso
stai ferma stai ferma stai ferma non ti
muovere
secondo me ho trovato la posizione
perfetta non si farà mai più male nella
vita allora l'obiettivo abbracciare il
tuo amico ubriaco che sul sofà mentre
c'è il cuscino addosso quindi cuscino
sul sofà ok cuscino cuscino cuscino ok
amico su stoffa è però non riesca a be
using perfetto resort level hoc e quindi
adesso posso star tranquillo per
possiamo provare la versione full
bene stai tranquilla tranquilla allora
stai stai ferma qui sai qui qui fermi
mettiti costo succedendo sono più briaco
io di questa mettiti ferma seduta
vabbè mi dai una mano eccola lì per me
almeno ti sei seduto bra brava la
bottiglia no la bottiglia in quel posto
9 st una posata ti sto infilando le
posate dove non vorrei dovrei prendere
la bottiglia bottiglia
la bottiglia ecco bra abbraccia la sedia
bene se ti chiedessi in una posizione un
po più corretta sarei più contento ma va
bene anche così ci accontentiamo economy
spiega il problema di questa tizia devi
stare sedute seduta seduta seduta o che
sia seduta sarebbe meglio se di siediti
poi con una mano alla soap energie sono
hulk tipio dell'acqua qui devo trovare
dell'acqua per far diventare mio amico
sobrio acqua dove l'acqua questa è acqua
né nella teiera tieni baby baby baby
quest'acqua buona bevuto o che trova un
modo per asciugare la tua amica
velocemente asciughiamo a c'è il
ventilatore tiratore di to get your
cavaco afferrato la palla non posso
mettere lei sopra il ventilatore invece
che il ventilatore sopra di lei ok sto
asciuga tipo i panni ora abbraccia il
tuo amico sul sofà va bene amico su
stoffa
mi siedo anch'io non so come ci si siede
il suo gioco più divertente di quella
volta che mi sono dimenticato come c
insieme
ecco come questo e un abbraccio vero da
amici che brutta storia va beh fa niente
complimenti per il desktop ordinato ma
vedendo come afferri il mouse lei le
cose non credo sia molto semplice di
averlo ordinato puoi fare una partita
alla playstation che lo lascio quasi
voglia adesso in teoria dovrei dovresti
st visu briaca zia perché ti ho versato
l'acqua addosso in teoria si può provare
a ballare in questo gioco a voi ea noi
ea farole steps yeah
c'è bisogno di una di una nota va bene
sentite proviamo a vedere se riesco a
cambiare personale campi cambiamo
personaggio non ci sono solo questi due
anni c'è un sacco di punti quindi
sblocchiamo e lina quindi io io uso e
lina e lina deve tenere alvin io sono e
li na e tengo che il mio amico ubriaco e
alvin alvin siediti che ci penso io
se riti che ci penso io a tenerti a
posto
vieni qui vieni qua stai qua albin
arrivo io con le cose
tieni non essere ubriaco baby che non
pensarci
bevi e non per baby è svenuto e stata
bellissima stage teiera 20 dell'acqua
sul tonico sobrio
va beh questo è veramente un ubriaco ma
forbice io non ho mai visto una persona
ubriaca
allora no sono scusami c'e la stoffa di
mezzo svegliati svegliati this ubriacare
prendi questo in teoria questo gioco non
è family friendly per niente ma non
saprei come ad es come descrivere a
youtube che non lo è
quindi secondo me rimane family friendly
solo perché youtube non saprebbe cosa di
cosa mi deve accusare versare acqua
della teiera sul mio amico ubriaco è un
reato pubblicare questa cosa su youtube
ma il perché non lo sanno neanche loro
bene così allora senti io c'ho questo e
questi sono fatti sono fatti apposta per
uccidere le persone tanto sono molto
sorpresa di questo a quanto vedo vorrei
alzarmi se possibile non non cadere per
favore fai
va beh allora che magari mi sblocca un
altro personaggio un po più che riesce a
usare ciò veramente pochi punti
harry sarebbe figo sarà perché il buffer
non funziona 180 punti per sporcare la
fronda i lo dobbiamo sbloccare la
famiglia mio personaggio è questo quello
che uso di là e alvin dai difficoltà 2
beh mi servono punti albini devo
sbloccare il bagno fammi sbloccare il
bagno no amico si è buttato per terra no
stai sul divano che lui mi servono punti
per il bagno
devo sbloccare vieni qua bibbie vieni
qua vieni qua
senti fratello non mi vieni qua stai
fermo lì mi servono i punti per il bagno
stai fermo questo è il cuscino questo e
cuscino lo prendi lo prendi selick st
bravo sul cuscino no sul divano o che
molto bene devo sbloccare il bagno avere
un sacco di punti col demonio sto
morendo ma come cammino severe
ne ho visti i giochi dove cammini storto
e per l'amor di dio ma questo li batte
quasi tutti sarà asciugati veloce cosa
vedo che musica metter adige in
discoteca spiegami perchè mi sa che era
molto più bella di quanto pensassi porti
anche a casa che si è asciugato il mio
amico ora lo devo abbracciare quindi
molliamo questo devi stare lì e
abbracciarti ok molto bene ma intitola
mi sa che ho sbloccato quanti punti ciò
porco demonio ancora no
maledizione te l'ho detto di non bere
perché si sia lasciata col tuo ragazzo
mannaia te l'ho detto io che non deve
abbracciare la cassa credo che questa
sia una delle scene più trash che io
abbia mai visto in tutta la mia vita ma
fa niente
siamo a volte una contro l'altra come è
sempre bello coltivare i propri amici
c'è nel senso di innaffiarli proprio è
sempre una cosa buona da fare cioè che
io sono capaci a fare soprattutto
asciughiamo tutto giusto
non ti fare male
mentre riposiamoci tutto giusto
abbraccio di gruppo ora se tu non la
smetti di bere mamma mia che meno
hai capito george hai capito stai qua
anche friends responso che lo argo dal
dalle natiche questo abbracciato dovrà
bruciare con tutte e due le braccia
immagino lo sto suonando tipo chitarra
va bene va bene è una cosa molto strana
a far vedere ma ok marmo alla loro in
realtà molla che va bene tutto molto
chiaro molto carino questo gioco mi
piace di crearmi crea dei disturbi prove
con un discorso a parte va bè ragazzi io
non saprei dare una definizione di
quello che ho appena giocato però
avvenne sono sempre dei tutorial che
fanno bene a saper come si vive come si
vive soprattutto spero ragazzi che vi
sia piaciuto come al solito il video è
piaciuto lasciare un commento
mi piace anche vari social che comitato
potrebbe schizzare se non se ne avresti
schiette vi lasciamo a un prossimo video
ubriaco che è un prossimo video di
passione da ragazzi
[Musica]